before its annexation by Japan Korea had
been ruled by the same royal family for
just over 500 years in 1910 when Korea
ceased to exist as an independent state
its royal family went with it yet when
Japan's empire fell and Korea became a
free country again Why didn't it restore
the royal family why did Korea opt to
become a republic so in the late 19th
century After Japan defeated China in
the first Ceno Japanese war China lost
its strangle hode over Korea sensing an
opportunity to safeguard Korean
Independence Emperor go Jong declared
the creation of the Korean Empire named
as such because it was not an Empire
this upset the Japanese but go Jong was
confident that they wouldn't do anything
because Russia stood as a counter to
balance them in the region that was
until Japan defeated them in 1905 after
which Korea became a Japanese puppet
state the Koreans weren't exactly happy
about this but the rest of the world
ignored their plight because upsetting
Japan over something as globally
insignificant as Korea wasn't worth it
these efforts led to the Japanese
government forcing out the emperor and
replacing him with his son sunjong this
new emperor was much better behaved and
he handed over most of the government's
competencies to Japan in 1910 the
Japanese formalized the arrangement with
the annexation of Korea and with that
there was no need for a royal family
there sunjong died without airs in 1926
and Japan would rule over Korea until
its own defeat in 1945 when that
happened Soviet forces had Advanced to
here the US and USSR had agreed to
divide Korea between them until a Korean
government was able to take over the
running of the country the original plan
was to allow Britain and China to also
run some of the country but the US and
USSR figured that those two didn't need
to be included and so they weren't which
meant that the only Power that actually
liked monarchy was out which certainly
didn't help and given that the last
people to actually run the place
independently served the Korean monarchy
why weren't they invited to return well
there were several reasons the first was
that simply it had been 35 years since
an independent Korean government had
existed and its former leaders were
somewhat too dead to help those that had
worked afterwards had been collaborators
with the Japanese and so weren't exactly
popular furthermore more the heir to the
Korean Throne Yun had also collaborated
with the Japanese and married a Japanese
princess none of which screamed free
Korea when the US occupied the south of
the country it sought to form a
provisional government and after some
bribe related Shenanigans it chose
singman re as its leader now there were
still some that called for the
restoration of the monarchy at this
point but the Americans weren't really
interested whilst monarchs were firmly
anti-communists so was re who also
wasn't interested in Sharing power and
had his moments of repressing murder to
make sure of that it also goes without
saying that in the north of the country
the USSR sponsored leaders weren't
exactly okay with the return of the
monarchy anywhere across the peninsula
when the Korean War began in 1950 the
monarchy ceased to matter in any way and
even after the fighting had stopped
reban members of the royal family from
returning to the country this was lifted
in 1963 at which point the koreas had
been republics for so long that the idea
of Reviving a monarchy that very few
even remembered wasn't a serious
proposal I hope you enjoyed this episode
with a special thanks to my patrons
James Bizet Kelly moneymaker K show wolf
Sky Chappelle kitka Anthony Becket rod D
Martin Udan Wang Marcus arner Y and
hockey Alex Schwin AF Firefly Captain
Cog Spencer liot Gustav Swan the MC
Whopper shenin Marvin CAU Winston kward
spinning three plates Andy McGee kimun
Yun calling Dr Howard Dr Fine Dr Howard
Todd short copper tone Maggie patkowski
words about books podcast Jim Stromberg
Miss iset and Charles I
first